les feux de forêt dans l'oeil des
pouvoirs publics qu'on se souvient des
incendies qui ont ravagé 30 000 hectares
de végétation l'an dernier en Gironde un
cas de figure qui n'est plus exclure en
région Centre-Val de Loire selon une
étude du ministère de l'Agriculture
alors à l'approche de l'été les pompiers
accentue leurs efforts de formation et
de prévention comme un pull constaté et
Sarago du côté de Chinon
lance en main c'est sapeurs-pompiers en
formation simule une défense de points
sensibles dans la forêt domanielle de
Chinon l'objectif protéger l'entreprise
du feu de forêt qui progresse dans sa
direction
donc ce sont les chefs degrés qui vont
nous dire si on doit ouvrir ou pas la
lance les professionnels s'apprêtent à
ouvrir les vannes pour créer une
barrière d'eau entre la forêt et le
bâtiment
les épisodes de sécheresse augmentent
les risques d'incendie aussi ce matin la
région organisé une journée de
prévention pour sensibiliser les divers
acteurs on a eu l'année dernière 1000
départs de feu sur la région c'est dire
que même si effectivement au niveau
national on a beaucoup parlé j'irai de
la Gironde et de la Bretagne on sait que
en Centre-Val de Loire d'ici 10 20 ans
on aura la même situation que dans les
Landes donc on se prépare on est plutôt
en avance géré dans les tous les
dispositifs qu'on met en place mais de
plus en plus effectivement nos élus les
parties prenantes sont conscients de ce
qui se passe et sont très demandeur
parmi ces dispositifs l'obligation
légale de débroussaillement elle
s'appliqua tous les détenteurs d'un bien
en zone forestière à risque d'incendie
en Indre-et-Loire l'arrêté préfectorale
date du 18 juillet 2022 en cas de
non-respects les propriétaires risquent
jusqu'à 15000 euros d'amende et un an
d'emprisonnement si le bail Non
débroussaillé est à l'origine du feu
face au changement climatique les gestes
de prévention deviennent de plus en plus
nécessaires
en cas de niveau de risque trop
important on prend des mesures de
précaution alors qui vont être gradués
en fonction du niveau du risque mais qui
vont être par exemple de décaler les
travaux de l'après-midi vers le matin
quand il fait plus frais que c'est plus
humide
d'interdire la circulation
publique sur des routes habituellement
ouvertes quand niveau de risque est trop
élevé en 2050 50% des forêts en France
seront soumises au risque d'incendie
élevés
comme ça on fait ça